All right,
welcome.
Thank you so much for coming.
So it took a lot of work to get this
play off the ground.
I don't want to say too much because I
don't want to spoil anything,
but all I'll say is I hope you enjoy
this as much as we enjoyed making it
either basic purpose of art is to
eliminate human nature.
Then I think comedy central's Nathan for
you deserves a spot in the conversation
about the best tv shows of this era.
A while ago I was working with a juggle
child.
His name was a dandy.
He was a great inspiration for me and
unfortunately,
tragically he died and when baboons
kidnapped and ate him,
not
only is it so funny that I cry laughing
at almost every episode,
but it reveals small truths about human
nature in a way that's unique.
I think for television in this episode,
for example,
Nathan on his never ending quest to help
small businesses meets a bar owner who
says her bottom line was cut in half by
laws that prohibit smoking indoors.
So to fix this,
Nathan finds a legal loophole that says
people can smoke inside if the smoking
is part of a theatrical production,
so we tell smokers to come back,
then invites a couple of theater goers
to sit in a special audience section
where they think they're watching a
legitimate play.
It's so funny because it's like so
nothing in a way but incredibly
profound.
There are three categories of people
involved in this scheme and the each
know different things.
Well,
four categories if you're counting
Nathan,
but we'll get to him later.
The first is ellen,
the bar owner.
She thinks Nathan is a business
consultant with a reality TV show who is
genuinely trying to help her by
exploiting a loophole in the law.
Then there are the bars,
patrons who think they found a place to
smoke inside without reproach.
Unlike Ellen,
the patrons don't know about the
theatrical framing,
presumably thinking that the audience
section is just another seating area in
the bar.
Finally,
there are the theater goers who don't
know about the business consultation and
genuinely think they're seeing an
experimental production.
There are a lot of ways that you can
read this show.
Full fat videos made an excellent piece
recently on how Nathan,
for you satirizes the phenomenon of fake
news.
I'll link to it below,
definitely check that out,
but one of the other key things I think
Nathan is interested in here is showing
us how people really act when normal
expectations are met with absurd
circumstances.
As John Teddy of the navy club once
said,
fielder uses the rank artificiality of
TV and TV making to extract this
surprising authenticity out of people.
Everybody involved in this setup knows
that they're being filmed.
They just don't know what they're being
filmed for or rather what they think
they're being filmed for is wrong,
and the dramatic irony opened up by the
difference between what they think and
what we know.
Let's a realness in their character
slipped through our realness.
They don't even know they're offering
the couple stands out to me because it
tells a story that maybe they're in a
new relationship and I think that
curiosity is what makes me want to
continue to watch.
Do you think this has theatrical merit?
You know,
this is slice of life theater and uh,
for that aspect,
I think it's important
for Nathan,
one level of artificiality is never
enough spurred on by the real praise of
his fake play.
He transcribes the real actions of the
patrons,
turns it into a real script,
and hire is real actors to play all the
parts.
Then he invites a real audience to watch
a real play,
which is all based on fakeness.
This time,
however,
all the people involved are aligned.
The actress think they're participating
in a play and they are.
The audience thinks they're watching a
play and they are an ellen.
Well,
who the hell knows what Elon thinks at
this point?
The only two categories of people who
really know better are Nathan and us.
The original pretense of the episode,
Helping Ellen with her business problem
is gone.
To have the external omniscient
perspective,
you actually need to know about the show
Nathan for you and what it's all about.
In fact,
that's what this moment is effectively
doing.
It's demonstrating the premise of the
show itself.
I hope you enjoy this play as much as we
enjoyed making it.
One aspect of this episode and really a
theme of the whole series is Nathan's
desperate attempts to connect with other
people.
Most of the time we're encouraged to
believe that Nathan is making people
uncomfortable for our benefit so that he
can reveal them to us.
I mean,
I wouldn't want to be a third wheel,
you know,
that's what it would be.
So.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah,
but the show also encourages us to
question that idea sometimes intensely
look into my eyes and say,
I love you.
I love you again.
Okay.
I love you.
Got It.
Oh yeah.
What you begin to realize is that no
one,
not even the TV audience,
can have a more omniscient perspective.
The nathans own.
There's only ever one man behind the
curtain though.
The show does make a pretty strong
argument that he too is unsure of
whether there's anything at the core of
all these layers of artifice,
of weird having cameras
around.
Right?
We can turn them off with a good way.
I feel like that.
Does that defeat the purpose?
I don't know.
What's the purpose,
Nathan,
for you is hands down one of the
funniest shows and TV history.
I'm obviously a huge fan and I've seen
some major results physically,
but there's more to this show within
just comedy.
Nathan uses comedy and the construct of
television to let us see into people's
souls these little interactions,
these moments of awkwardness,
insincerity,
what people are willing to say for
success,
what people are willing to go along with
to preserve the status quo.
These are the building blocks of
culture.
In the later chapters,
it actually says you spend a lot of time
volunteering with jungle children,
but I don't know what that is,
but you might want to bring it out
because audiences love someone who gives
back and is charitable.
Okay,
but I'll be able to.
I'll tell them,
you know what they want to hear.
It can be shocking to see people like
this and part of the reason we laugh is
to express this shock,
this embarrassment that seeing someone
so nakedly,
but I think this laughter is recognition
to in the end,
these people are really no different
than us who knows how we would react if
we found ourselves in one of Nathan
schemes without knowing it
work with a child named Andy who was a
very.
It was an inspiration and just like to
help and and,
and work with people with kids and at
that time,
tragically he was kidnapped and he was
eating by baboons at that time.
Hey everybody,
thank you so much for watching.
This one was a personal favorite of
mine.
I absolutely love the show and have for
a long time,
so thank you for watching.
This episode was brought to you by
squarespace.
If you want to make a website and you
want it to be a really easy process,
squarespace has some beautiful award
winning designer templates to choose
from.
That makes the process super simple.
It's got 24 hour customer service,
no upgrades,
nothing to install,
no patches ever.
And picking your domain name is really,
really easy.
You can start your free
trial@squarespace.com
and if you use the offer code
nerdwriter,
you can get 10 percent off your first
purchase.
Thanks guys.
I'll see you next time.